your thoughts on Seinfeld Seinfeld was
the greatest sitcom ever completely
changed how sitcoms work I believe that
anybody who wants to write the sitcom
form should study that show from
literally see every episode break it
down understand it because at every
level of comedy writing from story to
comedy lines to words
brilliant genius the the way they
handled characters was a revolutionary
Seinfeld was the first show to break the
conventional wisdom that said we have to
have cool likable characters right and
then this again came from the family
sitcom where everybody was in this nice
family but the good dad and the good mom
and the kids who would did do some
things wrong but nothing too serious
right everybody was so likable well all
of a sudden you had four people on
Seinfeld who were selfish they did often
really horrible things to each other and
to other characters on the show and they
were by all standards unlikable people
and yet we loved that show we would
follow that show and we liked those
characters because of their flaws not in
spite of it and so this changed
everything in television and the way
that especially television comedy
handled characters what's often not
really appreciated in a Seinfeld is it
was revolutionary in the way it handled
plot with the Seinfeld plot you had
typically four storylines that had to be
accomplished in 22 minutes
we still at the same 22 minutes so
instead of tracking a single storyline
we usually refer to as the a line we had
four lines that were generated by each
of the four primary characters on that
show now the advantage to that is you
get a much more complicated story weave
than you got on the traditional family
sitcom and that meant the plot was much
more complicated but where they took it
to another level was they didn't just
intercut four different story lines well
what is Elaine doing at this moment and
what is George doing at this moment and
so on
no the brilliant part was how they enter
woe of them so that they all came
together all four at one point at the
end of the story so I was referred to
the Seinfeld plot as a Zen show because
what they would do is always about some
kind of injustice that they were dealing
with some perceived injustice that they
were dealing with and they would always
come up with some seemed that they would
try to defeat this injustice right but
being this that this this Zen show the
Karma show what would happen is through
this incredibly intricate interwoven
four line plot we would get their
comeuppance we would get the real
justice that would come at the end in
and always a very surprising way and in
the the primary creative force behind
this was Larry David and he's really a
giant in the history of the sitcom form
and you can see essentially that same
approach to story that same approach to
plot in Curb Your Enthusiasm also taking
by the way the concept of the unlikable
character ten times further because with
the character on Curb Your Enthusiasm he
is purposely shoving your face in it as
I dare you to still watch when I do this
you know
when I go even farther I mean he is
George magnified by 10 times
you